Congratulations on the film guys I thought it was amazing. So Zendaya you're a trapeze
artist and Zac you're kind of running
the show a little bit so but if you were
actually at the circus what would you
want your special talent to be?
Oh well now that I've worked so hard to learn
the trapeze I'm gonna go with trapeze.
Yeah, I mean I got like a little taste of
the trapeze but I mean that requires a
lot of balance and upper body strength,
it's it's pretty pretty cool to watch.
Yeah I mean unless you've been in the
circus recently... You can be my catcher. Yeah, yeah, someone got to look after her, make sure there are two hands.
And how much of your own stunts did you do during the film?
As much as we could. I walked into rehearsal, I know for a fact she was all she did all her trapeze like
real flipping and catching trapeze I saw
that like on it's being executed on day
one for my rehearsals yeah first time I
walked in it was really her doing it I
couldn't believe it. I thought it was a
professional something and then it was her.
Like what the heck are you kidding?! I was pretty blown away.
And it's very A list cast, what was it
like working with Hugh Jackman and Michelle Williams?
A list! It was awesome, I mean Hugh Jackman's like my hero, so yeah yeah I really look up to that guy.
And still do! He's so cool, so nice,
hard-working, determined like all the
great positive things you could possibly
say just go ahead and say it about Hugh
and everybody will back it up because
he's just everyone you mean it's like
isn't even nicest guy he's like yeah
he's like the nicest guy! That's exactly what you get if
anyone has ever met Hugh says the nicest
things about him so naturally I was skeptical.
Like does he ever have a bad day you know? Is he ever not in a good mood and just like a wonderful human? No!
He confessed to me he has had one before. Really? Yeah a long time ago.
He remembered he had a bad day. He never shows it. Its so funny because after knowing him then
I went to go see Logan after and I was
like he was like you know he's cussing
and he's you know mad I'm like it's like
so like you'd like so different!
See you couldn't be that as good as he was and in Logan without having at least one or two bad days! You have to have something to draw from.
It was really neat, it was while we were filming that Logan came out so we were seeing this side of Hugh that was totally you know
dancing and so excited to be at work and then we went and saw Logan. Like ugh! Like shing, through the head. Oh my gosh he's so angry! And then so happy at work.
He had to get it out while he was doing Logan. Those are when the bad days happened!
I love the sound track so much what are your favorite songs?
They're all really unique and catchy and different and so
I don't know that it depends. Daily honestly. Yeah it really depends daily or where you're at
in the movie but all the songs are they
serve they serve a really unique purpose
and you connect with each moment
differently. So I mean our numbers catchy
you can hear it on the radio, like it's
it's a classic love ballad which I really enjoy.
But then I mean Rebecca Ferguson sings the song, what's it called?
Never Enough. Yeah and then it's so powerful. And then when the little kids are singing at the beginning...
A Million Dreams? Is that what it's called?
Yeah, exactly see you love that one.
Exactly so I don't know. It changes! This Is Me. Keala is killing that every time. Yeah and then the Coming Home one.
I don't know they're all good seriously you'll know what we mean when you see it. Yeah, check it out.
It was written, a lot of the songs were written by the
same writers is the La-La Land sound
track and there's been a little bit of
Oscars buzz already. What do you make of that?
I'm not gonna jinx anything. I don't know, there has been? Yeah! From who? From Oscar?
THE Oscar?! The press! People talking. That's that's nice to hear, that's really, that's awesome.
Very chill about it. Don't want to jinx it. That's awesome, thank you!